Oh cancel culture left and right people
are getting cancelled who's next
Felix Kjellberg I'm coming for you
you're about to get came so you're done
I know all your secrets Oh
[Laughter]
not funny should not joke about serious
things sorry I forgot today we're doing
a video on you belays should we cancel
celebrities for their crimes where they
discuss about canceled culture they'll
gather people in a room some are for
canceled culture other people are
against it let's say what they have to
say and I hope I can give some insight
as well as a YouTube egg big person
let's go our Kelly bye I'm done with you
get out of here like but that's in your
opinion I'm not saying I'm here for our
our Kelly I just think if you support
him your dick right yeah and then there
you go everyone everyone hates our Kelly
no matter what sight on the spectrum
you're on we can all agree our Kelly is
done this should be a fruitful
conversation it's so funny because on
the internet everyone loves to be so
divided we have it's basically like
everyone is driving into cars so it's
okay to yell at each other but you get
people that don't agree on the topic in
the same room and all the sudden I think
this is a natural human trait that we we
are naturally agreeable it's kind of
funny I just threw that in there for no
reason it's just an observation that has
nothing to do with the point okay let's
keep watching
yeah I guess
guess who there cancel culture people
are
be a liability Eilish stand over here
doesn't like our Kelly hello my name is
a deep Kadir he's amped about science to
City and I'm a product manager in the
tech industry hi I'm will Kourt I'm a
music student at USC hi I'm joy Villa
I'm a singer-songwriter and I am anti
cancel culture like I she said that I'm
actually anti mm-hm they got a nice
diverse group I was saying and I should
be interesting ish cancel culture more
on this I'd been looking forward to this
conversation hi I'm Seth Fowler Law
School graduate there's a hot take I'm
against cancel culture but everyone
everyone that is for canceled culture
needs to be canceled they need a taste
on their own medicine we'll get into it
I have so much to say about this we'll
get into it
I would buy an artist work even if they
committed a violent crime mm-hmm I would
be inclined to say no because obviously
I don't want to support anyone that does
violent crimes but on the second hand
it's very circumstantial what if they're
defending themselves then I think is
fair game but then on the other hand I
probably supported a lot of rappers that
done for violent crimes
it's like rappers are not part of a big
group let's get real here it's teenage
girls in charge of any cancer culture
movement feel free to tell me if I'm
wrong there's a reason trap hasn't been
cancelled yet let's get real here humans
are a series of impulses on a spectrum
of time like we are constantly changing
we're constantly evolving I have any of
you have honestly never not told a lie
in your life of course we evolved us so
are you a liar today boom what an
argument that's a great point actually
that new ones has never put today you
can tell clearly with people digging up
old videos and using that
as evidence if we want to do castle
culture I feel like we need like a
certain time we need to get more
organized as what I'm saying certain
time frame I guess that's the thing like
you know a Shane is someone getting
cancer right now and you know you watch
it clips and you're like jeez but it
doesn't say when they're made or and
stuff like that same with Jenna you know
you watching her like but then knowing
oh that was actually 9 or 10 years ago
that to me at least I'd changes things
online and especially if I know that
person has grown out of that that
doesn't make it okay what they did but
at the same time I don't see a pretty
reason dragging someone to the dark
because of it I'm trying to argue both
sides here like I think it's good that
there's a clear line of what's okay
today by maybe referencing things in the
past but I also don't think there's a
good reason to cancel something for what
they did in my mind's eye I don't know I
don't say anything
yeah damn it I haven't thought about
this properly I think the issue with
canceled culture is it's kind of like
this like you have a cut on your arm
let's just chop the whole arm off yeah
it's also I like this guy's got good
points I like that very good good
metaphors it's true he's not wrong he's
not wrong he's right the amount of
people that work on some of these
projects like think of like a Harvey
Weinstein movie right he did terrible
things I wouldn't want to port support
Harvey Weinstein but most of his victims
are people that were in his movies by
not supporting the Harvey Weinstein
movie are also not supporting his
victims so it's kind of like you're in a
weird spot it sounds like a weird
argument but I actually agree with him
because for me example I mean oh [ __ ]
honestly Harvey Weinstein movies a
hundred percent
there will be more movies they will be
okay but at the same time looking at
from my perspective with the scare
PewDiePie getting cancelled I feel
terrible about every one that worked and
I hundreds of people that never got to
show all this all the guests that we
have all that so many people on the set
planning organizing money all this stuff
that never got to show anything for it
because of me and that doesn't feel fair
to them and I'm sorry like honesty is
point but with hard
one scene that you can't bring down the
kingpin without bringing down the
organization that he built I guess
that's the problem now everyone is a
kingpin apparently you got a YouTube
channel it's like people are massively
overestimating our influence when it's
convenient and massively undermining it
when they feel like it
ahem he's just irrelevant
can you believe he posted this for his
hundred of millions of subscribers many
times I hear that whenever it's
convenient the argument switches it's
great so he said something very
interesting to me about like the whole
cutting off the arm and to fix a cut and
I feel like the exact opposite because
when you talk about how like you get
another arm is that what you meant oh if
you're canceling people bond they have
good inventions it's like there's so
many smart people there are so many
smart people that's where you're wrong
that's why I can't cancel culture exists
there's too many dumb people that's the
problem oh my god remember last year
when James Charles was cancelled and the
entire world was so sure that he was a
creditor and the amount of people that
spread that message around causing him
to almost end up being suicidal did we
learn anything from that no no one
learned anything absolutely nothing if
anything is his worst now did we learn
maybe we shouldn't point fingers before
we know the full truth no no that does
not happen anymore those days are over
powers in our hands and I feel like for
me I'm doing my part by not choosing not
to like mess with that person anymore
look how conveniently they're putting
this what a hat facts argument right
that is not cancel culture saying that
you don't want to listen to someone who
[ __ ] cares no one's gonna stop you
the problem is that canceled culture
wants them to stop making whatever that
is they're making they want the the
platform or all these things that's the
point of cancer culture saying that oh
I'm just like I don't want to listen to
them anymore
no that is not how it works your music
should be continued to be sold and
available
personally don't think so just don't
listen to don't buy you yourself yeah
absolutely every individual has the
right to say hey I don't like this and
you can even tweet about saying no but
then to start a boycott that's what yeah
people are different morally I
personally have the right I withhold the
right I think all of us do to not go and
support these people we don't believe in
I would never tell you wait I'm gonna go
see XYZ movie and you have to - if you
say no you have that right what cancel
culture does is saying I'm not gonna see
this person because I don't like this
person is buddy I'll shoot that's why I
hate it and smart people I like them
like a militant so culture is out of
control what the hell is that
when was this film when it started a
2090 was a good thing it's like the me -
movement a good thing I agree you know
you had all these victims the police
didn't listen what else are you gonna do
now that now it's like wait you say you
were this and that why didn't you go to
the police oh they're not gonna listen
anyway you should still go to the police
if it's just easier I was right
something when you get the court of
public opinion involved I tell you it
becomes so horrible I am an artist I've
legitimately hit number one on Billboard
people think oh I wish you throw that in
there this is like I don't run my social
media I absolutely do I read comments I
respond even negative ones when people
say I hope you die somebody should kill
your family you should get raped so that
you you have a baby illegitimate you can
I mean it is online bullying cancel
culture rationally is overall a net
positive I think but there are sects of
cancel culture like the toxic people
that issue the death threats then of
course those need to be excised cancel
culture originated out of compassion the
voice for I guess that's the problem no
one holds the people the people that are
part of the hate mob accountable you
know I think I think the James Charlie
Singh is such a good example because
everyone wants so on board with
canceling games and
now people are definitely defending
James to the point where they go after
other people for whatever reason I'm
just saying that is the thing that
happened but wait a minute you were
first you were ready to cancel him you
don't get the right to switch around you
know if an influencer did that in turn
they would be held accountable but for
the amass group of people that that just
doesn't exist so it's like they're
expecting everyone else to be better but
everyone part of castle culture are no
better than self I think so at least
and speaking of which taught the upload
of the video and I wanted to address it
so badly because I hate her so much
but I'm just so done with all of this
it's so childish it feels pity to even
comment about like YouTube drama and all
this council stuff that's going on I'm
just like I don't want to participate in
this this is just ridiculous and I don't
even care who's right at this point it's
like let's say you wanted to boycott
coca-cola or Nike or something imagine
if stores started taking Nike shoes out
of the store before you could even make
the decision as a people to buy it or
not buy it and we need to have the right
and in the option that our love is I
mean technically I'm sure if something
really bad came out about a big brand
they probably wouldn't shelf it right
because it looks bad on them so that the
argument isn't really bulletproof I'm
just playing devil's advocate here for
the sake of it and also it's almost like
YouTube is still so new and people have
been doing it for so long when the
internet was basically the Wild West and
people said and did whatever they did
wanted and that's kind of when it's part
of the charm of YouTube people could
express themselves completely freely but
now with more advertising and more
people watching it's clearly slowly
developed into a mainstream
something more on the ground sub
corporate sort of cleanness and that
seems to just be the standard for now on
you know II from someone that's been
through all this cancer time I've
definitely become so much more aware of
not just what I say but how what I say
can be perceived because it's not just
what you meant
by communicating something it's it's if
you can take a portion or what you said
and it seems like something else that's
enough so that's how careful you gotta
be when you articulate yourself and yeah
a lot of times it's not even worth it
that's why I don't like doing piu news
anymore because it's just too much to
keep up with and I just and and then I
don't I felt done with drama and Papa
Gloria died as well which is so sad
I know people some people who think oh
that's so sad he doesn't do it anymore
and he it's not right but I also feel
like I'm too old man
I don't care this is not why I started
YouTube and I mean no way expressing
myself here so let's keep watching sorry
for all the rainbows trying to make you
not buy the product I think that they're
saying as a company we do not agree with
this so we're not gonna sell your
product here when record labels stop
playing their music or whatever I feel
like it's justified specifically for
victims because when it gets out that
that person did something like that
their music skyrockets and for the
victim seeing that they're getting so
much and then once your cases are over
sure you can play their music more if
they are innocent but it's also like the
justice system isn't always right I
gotta say people have a very childish
sense of justice it's almost like at a
childlike level it's probably just me I
don't think most people would agree on
this to me if someone did me bad I
wouldn't feel justice just because other
people found out other people need to
know this person is bad because
otherwise it's not fair to me I think
that a lot of people think that way and
it's a very childish way of looking at
things
oh this person treated me badly I'm not
trying to downplay one no there's
obviously many bad things happening and
there's also things that seem come out
and seem very trivial you know again
referencing that as an example so people
don't take what I say out of context the
toffee and James situation where Tati
was mad Lizzy tobert was mad that her
friend promoted a brand that wasn't hers
and that was all it took to create the
biggest cancel drama in the history of
YouTube that's basically the mindset of
this person did something bad to me now
I need to do so
bad for them and other people need to
know about it that's what I mean this is
we're clear just to be clear don't
cancel me uh if I have a problem with
someone i other stop talking to them or
I work it out in private but that
apparently does not exist because
everyone on this website is a mental Lea
develop underdeveloped child the public
should hold celebrities accountable when
the justice system fails have people not
being taught that the world isn't there
and is never going to be that doesn't
mean you should try obviously but it's
like it seems so basic I don't get it
I clearly don't get it this is my take
on it our Kelly is the first name that
comes to mind because he has sex tapes
that show his face and people are still
like didn't do it
we love our Kelly he would never and
most of the time when it's a celebrity
being convicted they can always buy
their way out
that's exactly they came to mind for me
too what does she mean buying her weight
their way out not getting good lawyers
yeah I can see that actually that's what
happened with I've seen them isn't it
it's a fair point how many times in like
the United States justice system have we
seen guilty people get off innocent and
they find off years later that that
happened if such a lot of times it does
happen and I think especially it happens
when you are basing decision around
anger and this important sense of
justice now it needs to happen now
instead of in a court of law where it's
carefully examined and impartially
examined I think that's important
justice system doesn't come through we
as a people shouldn't that yeah again no
one's waiting for the justice anymore
everyone just found a shortcut that's
the problem what's important and what's
happening now is that we do look at
replacing whether it's the district
attorney or whatever the system is
that's causing it to fail people should
go and address this so the next millions
of people that go through that system go
through a justice this room I think we
all completely agree with that like the
justice system needs to be fixed but I
do think there
reason canceled culture started and when
it originally derived was because like
to be 100 like that takes so long like
for our entire government and justice
system to like evolve until you're
idealistic view of it is not happening
next year we're I think we're making
change I think it's happening but I
think our generation that spawned
canceled culture was like you don't have
time we have the same problems with kids
it doesn't matter how it started what
the problem is what it is now which is
ironically the problem with canceled
culture because they don't seem to draw
any distinction on the past and present
apparently I just think if you support
him you're a dick
right yeah I hate how they're bringing
up our Kelly yeah everyone can agree on
that but the problem is so much more
nuanced than name but I like
compassionate canceller culture if you
look at the history of somebody and you
look at how somebody responds when
confronted they're not discussing any of
the nuances they're just speaking very
broadly you know it's so easy to take
clip or a portion of someone said or
literally just spread rumors online
that's enough for people who jump on
board and cancel someone these are the
issues to me I I think it seems like
everyone agrees there should be
something happening to bad people yeah
we can all agree on that there should be
some repre caution but it they're not
discussing any of the issues that a
moles within it we all kind of have the
same opinion on a level we think that
people deserve console myself yes but I
feel like we oh my god
good talk yeah I appreciate a civil
conversation but Jesus Christ that was
at least productive thing I've ever seen
in my life
let's see what the comment has to say
cuz I'm curious it depends yep cancel
culture isn't activism it's virtuous
signaling on social media to get clock
points on the internet cancel culture
works in a way to where people are guilt
to improve until proven otherwise which
is a large reason why it's so toxic
[ __ ] sake is this aimed at James
Charles well yeah I think it must have
been uploaded at the same time it's such
a perfect example but no one learned a
single thing and it blows my mind dude
the same people that are like we need to
cancel James Charles can you believe
James Charlesworth suicide on we should
have canceled culture cards and pass
them out you get one alright yet one
everyone gets one and then you have to
shut the [ __ ] up that's my solution I
think people just have to be brave
enough to stand up you know I know I
referenced James Charles scenario
million times already but when I looked
at that I couldn't make sense of why
everyone was canceling James over
something so trivial and something
allegations that were not proven at that
point I think I'm probably more prone to
look at things more openly since I've
technically been cancelled as well and I
hope the public will catch on it seems
like in general most people in these
comments seems to be against it but the
problem is when you get a big group very
worked up no one wants to come in
between and say no because then they'll
jump on you and that's just how it is
everyone loves canceled culture until
you're the one being canceled curious
about your thoughts on this leave some
comments down below maybe we can have a
discussion
thank you for watching I'm gonna take
two days off and see ya tomorrow no two
days thanks to all the members I've been
really happy that we can do support
different charities month thanks to all
the members and I'm happy to be able to
do something positive in these times
that internet just seems so incredibly
heavy when I said as well as the final
point whether that I'm careful with what
I say now because an effective council
culture it's not that I'm you know I'm
not even scared of being canceled it's
more the fact that I I just want to
enjoy YouTube like if people came after
me for dumb reasons I know how to defend
myself the problem is most people aren't
equipped with the tools to deal with the
giant hate mob and that's what leads
people to cancel themselves you know
people like Jenna Jenna Bob was to quit
YouTube recently because of the clips
she did always eight nine eight ten
years ago because she's just fed up with
it which is completely reasonable
completely understandable but I hope she
comes back IIIi think people don't
realize this sort of what kind of ball
of pain they're inflicting on an
individual by doing these things because
you might think over just getting them
canceled or we're just getting them to
monetize or whatever but it's so much
more of an item and whenever there's a
big hate mom going at someone you might
you might not see it but there are
people doing extreme things like sending
death threats Daxing go into addresses
calling parents calling jobs doing all
these things that maybe you don't even
think about if you think we're just
doing this you deserves it there's so
much more to it that isn't it just isn't
right and it's not appropriate that was
my final thought for some reason I felt
like I hadn't talked enough okay
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten
what creatures fought spells and poop
troops awaits hoopty is coming to
Nintendo's wait and remember it has a
very big TV pre-order promotion I mean a
gave me a checkbook particular banjo
[Music]